what are we doing right um the key thing
the US is doing wrong in terms of energy
policy overall I think it's letting
Congress mandate foolish foolish
legislation like the the ethanol scam
the Congress in December of 2007 passed
the energy independence and security act
of 2007 and in doing so mandated the
production of 36 billion gallons of
ethanol by 2022 it is not going to
happen this I mean that what they have
done is mandate the creation of a huge
amount of motor fuel that the market
cannot supply but what is also happening
is that they are increasing demand for
corn and thereby and therefore other
grains as causing enormous amounts of
inflation in food prices and it's
hurting consumers all over the country
so I think what the US has been doing
wrong with regard to energy policy is
allowing Congress to meddle too much in
the market and mandate certain solutions
that are not economic and are not
helpful what is the u.s. doing right you
know I don't have to think about that
one because there no there are no
answers that come to mind I think that
we've we've really the mistake that we
are making as well in addition to the
ethanol is relying on militarism the US
has really since the 1970s in particular
had an approach to energy security that
and that requires wrongly over
militarization of the Persian Gulf which
I think has been a very very deleterious
effects on the US the second Iraq war
was no matter how you slice it was in
fact about controlling the flow of oil
out of Iraq and resting the control of
Iraq's oil from Saddam Hussein meanwhile
other countries around the world have
have turned to the marketplace they are
not using militarism as a way to trying
to assure energy supply and they are
thriving and we're going bankrupt